hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to fishy now a lot of you
guys out there have asked me very
personally to play feed and grow which
is a game where you play as a fish or a
shark or any other sort of ocean
creature and then you eat every other
thing in the ocean and you imbibe them
in your body and you absorb their
nutrients and somehow you grow bigger
from that but in order for me to play
that game I have to go back and play
fishy which is a game that I've talked
about when I play agario asla Vario a
tasty planet I've talked about this game
oh my here's what the [ __ ] shut up oh my
god that just exploded my eardrums okay
so this is fishy and fishy is basically
the same game as thus I just described
you are a tiny little fishy you're kind
of the smallest fish in the entire pond
but your objective is to eat and give
our engines your B yeah you're even
using and hopefully don't touch any fish
that's bigger than you because
everything is trying to eat everything
not what it's [ __ ] oh come back I love
you
oh yeah now the thing about this game is
okay now the thing about this game is I
played this this came out in 2003 I was
just at the cusp of hitting puberty for
the first time my voice cracks quite a
bit now so I'm not sure I ever got
through it I played this so long ago
that I can't exactly remember where I
was the first time that I played it but
it's a really cool game in that the
simplicity of it kind of lends to making
it a more interesting experience I mean
I heard you sure you ah okay ah okay
never mind
rebounding off the top who's getting a
bit deadly so basically it's a game of
patience you have to wait for the right
fish to come across your path and then
make the mistake of ever saying hi to
you because you're a horrible fish
just reaps destruction everywhere you go
in the beginning it's very slow because
obviously you have to wait for your prey
to approach you and you have to make
sure there are other eyes eyes that guy
wanted to come across I apologize my
voice is a little raw from no other
reason than I was screaming a lot
yesterday I wasn't recording or anything
else I I just like to stand on my
rooftop and tell my neighbors how
awesome I am in case I didn't notice for
all the other times enough I've screamed
in videos and left the window open um
but basically what I was doing yesterday
is I was playing a game and I won't see
what game it is because I'm still gonna
play it again but I spent an hour
recording it like super high energy it
was a fun engaging game and then the
recording blew up for no [ __ ] reason
other than the universe wanted to say
[ __ ] you mark apply you're an [ __ ]
anyway but that's what I was doing
yesterday so it was a lot of fun and
just utter disappointment and then I ate
my feelings and potato chips and French
onion dip but you can tell this is a
true story because of the specificity of
how I covered up my shame with potato
chips and I hadn't even I hadn't even
like I've been trying to eat healthy for
a long time but I was so pissed off that
I actually went to the store exclusively
to buy junk food for me to eat which I'm
sure is something that you guys have
never ever done before when you have
something go wrong in your life but for
you it's probably something important
for me it's just my recording with bad
wasted a lot of energy and my voice
hurts also the date just the day just
before um I I put out a vlog yesterday
that was basically telling you guys that
there was this um Warcraft thing that we
were doing uh it's in promotion of the
movie Warcraft that's coming out because
I'm a big fan of World of Warcraft I've
been playing it on and off since it
first came out but I I love the game a
lot and they got like 30 youtubers
together in one place youtubers and
Viners and a whole bunch of other people
a lot of people that I met for the first
time there which was real
cool um in one place for us to play a
full-length game of capture the flag in
real life so we have these like powdered
balls you'll see the video when it first
comes out they actually didn't give me
an authentic release date for when that
was gonna happen but they told me it was
gonna be relatively soon
um so expect that video I'll let you
know when it's coming out I I don't know
if it's gonna be on my channel it might
be on a different channel so but it's
gonna be awesome because the game was
super fun it was very very like like a
physically demanding I mean I've been
getting in shape I've been doing a lot
of exercise recently but this was just
taxing to a completely different degree
because we uh what happened was we
played I don't even know if I should
talk about that but we played a whole
bunch we played for a long time because
they were obviously filming it and they
wanted to make sure they got all the
right shots and whatnot so we we were
playing a true God Oh
jeezum sounds close we were playing it
for a long time uh but it wasn't fake or
staged any of the playing so we
legitimately had to play over and over
again which was fine it was totally fun
I don't mind that at all but we had to
play for like an hour and a half
straight of just non-stop pro dodging
and basically being a badass that I am
in the face of adversity and the Horde I
was team captain for the Alliance which
is really weird considering my red hair
but that's fine don't worry about it
cool so the finished product will be
available soon ish probably sometime
before the movie comes out I'm not 100%
on when that'll be but I will let you
guys know it's getting a bit dicey err
for some reason I don't know why I think
it's because I'm bigger so basically the
margin of error for me to miss other
creatures that are bigger than me has
shrunk down tremendously and I need to
concentrate now because I could actually
get screwed over at any moment
and I don't know what kind of freakish
creature exists I really hope it doesn't
actually exist
ooh that's I think I could eaten that
guy but I'm not gonna risk it I'm
playing it safe here because it takes a
long time to be able to climb back onto
the top of the whoa this was a bad move
that was a bad move that was a very
oh god this war if like a fast-fish
should come across just at that moment I
would have been so screwed whoa I got
picked up speed right towards Ely
back it's the fast ones if you get on
you you just want to get my steez I'm
gonna get them eventually they're gonna
know what true pain is your larger okay
yes oh man that could have been a
sweeping strike I wasted my opportunity
I'm not good enough Oh God
I think I'm playing it too safe actually
now I'm probably playing just say so
just just safe enough just exactly the
level of safe that I desire yeah I knew
I could eat those guys I knew I could
get in my mouth Milton I wanna use that
out of contact plays whoo [ __ ] whoa good
move good oh okay good move good oh good
move good move good move good move I
like how I'm patting myself on the back
no one else here is gonna celebrate my
victory so I got to be the one that
really really makes sure that I circle
Dirk my felt nice Oh God don't get
trapped whoo [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
ah [ __ ] wall that's dangerous going up
on the edge at the screen like that that
was almost death oh man I'm shocked that
I made it out of that one alive
oh god oh god don't lose it oh god it's
okay
Oh everything's fine everything's fine
everything's fine everything's fine I'm
almost to the point where I can easily
claim victory because once you reach a
certain size you just start eating
absolutely everything and that's good
okay
good good good good good oh I think I
couldn't eaten that guy that would have
been a close call though so I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna risk it just yet
not just yet not just you yes you I
think you but I'm not gonna Wow Oh oh
come on oh [ __ ] that dammit
curse you fish eh I'm back in good job
me well done me you did a great job me
well thanks me I really appreciate it by
the way can I say that me looks pretty
good today well I'm glad me said that me
looks good today I was wondering if
anyone who's gonna say the me looks good
me thanks me no problem me I'll see you
later me if you know that if if me know
what me mean me if me if hey getting
dangerous in here it's really bad for
[ __ ] me Oh chica damn it you bastard
[ __ ] these fish don't [ __ ] these fish
bad advice if I was being really finicky
about this and wanted to go for the high
score you got to get the things that are
very close to your size but not too big
so you got to like judge it because you
get scores based on how big the fish is
that you eat but you only grow bigger
based on the number of fish you've eaten
so Oh God
oh oh no oh no oh that was dangerous so
is that but I like to live dangerously
very dangerously I think I could in that
one I could definitely lose
yeah not that maybe that one that one
yeah I can eat that one
[ __ ] yeah was even as I was going into
that when I was not 100% sure about that
whoo yeah so it's just it's just
quantity based for the size but if you
want to secure ultimate victory you got
your good jab in but I'm not I'm not
doing that
I'm just saying for you guys if you ever
want to get the high score on this who I
can eat that guy oh [ __ ] I'm getting big
now it's getting serious um this guy
definitely yeah that guy Ron okay I'm
almost there
yeah yeah yeah yeah oh oh [ __ ]
ah that guy actually was close this guy
yeah this guy okay now we're getting
there now we're getting it whoa still I
don't think big blues I don't think big
blues just yet Robert a hobbit
okay how have it wobba
whoa have it not the biggest of the
Blues yet but I can get that guy yeah
yes I can yes I can yes I can
oh I think we've I think we've crossed
the threshold
I think we've crossed the ultimate
threshold the threshold of Awesome yes
little Susie's not so little anymore
little fishie has come to destroy little
fishie injury to conquer the Oh John
Reynolds is here dare to disrupt egotism
little fishy is will literally causing
the end of the fishy world cuz I'm kind
of agree bastard Jessica need everybody
did boy Oh nobody bother fishy little
fishies swimming in the sea
okay yeah just getting good this is
pretty much to the point of
ridiculousness now but this is what
happens when you play in frisky I'm
sorry my voice is going um but what is
what happens when you play fishy you
eventually as something analogous to
political [ __ ] or something now to
no economic I don't know but you eat a
lot you get bigger get so big that you
just start eating everything and nothing
else can survive is
that lovely what a great way to end the
entirety of the ocean God little fishy a
big holy [ __ ] wow that's a quite a fish
I'll just I'll just sit here now I don't
expend any more energy I'll just let
them sail directly into my mouth I can't
expect to be work for my meat what I
can't expect to work for my meat so I'm
just gonna wait for my meat to do anyway
let's just look it's like my body's
undulates and grabs fish in and pulls
them into my skin directly just mother
mother mother mother I just have to
sweep up and down sorry everybody all
right I'm not sorry I'm not sorry in the
least
not even remotely sorry well you ate
everything and completely destroyed the
pond ecosystem well then I get to move
to the ocean and then everything gets to
die out there but anyway I finally
played the game that I've always talked
about this is fishy I've said I don't
know how many times that I've ever said
this game but it's a cool game and it's
one of the earliest that I've ever
played
on Newgrounds and it's just fun so thank
you everybody so much for watching you
can try to beat my high score by
clicking through the link in the
description below so thanks again and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
sorry that's
oh I got 50 rats three cats